แล้ว Qiskit คืออะไร
Qiskit คือชุดพัฒนาซอฟต์แวร์โอเพนซอร์ส
สำหรับการทำงานกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ในระดับ circuit
อัลกอริทึม และโมดูลแอปพลิเคชัน SDK นี้
ช่วยให้ทุกคนสามารถโปรแกรมบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจริงได้จาก
แล็ปท็อปของตัวเอง แค่สองบรรทัดโค้ดก็สามารถเข้าถึง
ระบบควอนตัมหลายแบบ ตั้งแต่ superconducting
ไปจนถึง trapped-ion qubit อยากจำลองพฤติกรรมของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมแทน
แค่เปลี่ยนโค้ดหนึ่งบรรทัด
แล้วจำลอง quantum circuit บนสมรรถนะสูงของเรา
Qiskit เป็นเครื่องมือที่ใช้โดยคนหลายหมื่น
คนทั่วโลก ทุกคนพยายาม
สร้างอนาคต ไม่ว่าจะเป็นนักวิจัย นักพัฒนา
หรือแค่อยากเริ่มต้น
Qiskit มีฟีเจอร์มากมาย
พร้อมรองรับความต้องการของคุณ
ให้ทุกคนทำสิ่งต่าง ๆ ได้
เช่น สร้าง quantum circuit แรกของคุณ
รันอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมข้ามโดเมน
และศึกษาปรากฏการณ์ควอนตัมพื้นฐาน
บางทีตอนนี้อาจเป็นเวลาที่ดีที่สุดที่จะเข้ามามีส่วนร่วมด้วยตัวเอง
และหาเครื่องมือทั้งหมดที่ต้องการ
รวมถึงเครื่องควอนตัมจริง
และ SDK ผ่าน Qiskit
และชุมชนที่ยินดีต้อนรับ
และตอบทุกคำถามที่คุณอาจมีตลอดทาง
เริ่มต้นได้เลยวันนี้
ที่ Qiskit